but we start with breaking news tonight
Metro Police investigating a homicide in
the Northeast Valley
happened on Charleston near Christy Lane
Ryan Matthey joining us live now Ryan at
the scene
yeah well Denise Brian one man appearing
to be homeless found dead here behind a
business you can see investigators still
here investigating the whole scene they
say that they discovered this body hours
earlier though around six o'clock this
evening now Metro's homicide Lieutenant
says while canvassing the area for a
witness of an unrelated investigation
they found a homeless encampment behind
the Las Palmas Indoor Swap Meet near
Charleston and Sloan one white male in
his 50s or 60s found deceased with stab
wounds well we don't know when the
stabbing occurred who did the stabbing
in if this is random or not the
lieutenant adds that the up tops or the
autopsy will eventually determine more
about how this man died as they are
still unclear on much of this man's
death at the moment but for the meantime
they are asking anyone who had
potentially seen anything in this area
again near the area of Charleston and
Sloan around or just after six o'clock
today to contact them as they are
investigating trying to find video of
the scene and trying to find witnesses
who may have witnessed anything that
happened here for now reporting live
near Charleston and Sloan Ryan Matthey 8
News Now